Daniel: Hello.
Welcome to the course physics as
Information Processing.
Taught by Chris Fields, with Aguirre
Aguire as a course assistant.
Hosted during 2023 by the Active
Inference Institute, this video is an
overview of the course website.
It's going to cover some of the key
pieces of the website and ways to
participate.
The course homepage hosts the key links
and a written course overview.
On the course syllabus page there's a
table with each row being one session.
So here you can see the topic and the
preparation for each of the six lectures.
.
And you can see information about the six
discussion sections which will be
following each lecture by about two weeks.
.
Each lecture and discussion, you can
click this blue icon and go directly to
the video to rewatch it or watch it live.
.
Or you can go to the playlist to watch
all videos sequentially.
So that's one way that you can
participate is watching videos live or
rewatching them.
On the Questions and Answers page there's
a form that you can submit.
You can say what is time?
And if you submit that question, we'll
get it on the back end and Chris Fields
will answer the question, and then the
question and answer will come up to the
public front end and along with the
transcripts of all sessions, these
questions and answers will be part of the
publication that we prepare at the end of
the course.
So we heartily encourage all questions
and answers.
It's a really easy and important
anonymous way for you to contribute.
Lastly, you can go to register to join
discussions.
So if you want to join those live
interactive discussion live streams,
about two weeks after each lecture, you
can complete this form and we'll add you
to calendar events.
So thanks again for your interest in the
course Physics'information Processing and
we hope to see see you either watching
and rewatching the videos, asking
questions and answers and maybe even
registering to join the discussions.
Thanks and see you there.